Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özübal. Ich bin auf der Station Assistan Asteidik.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Ja klar.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Erstmal werden wir ein paar Personen untersuchen, dann können wir weiterführen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Maya Müller.
Maya Müller.
Müller, ja.
Müller. Mit wie?
Könnten Sie bitte Vorname und Nachname langsam buchte werden.
Okay.
Super, danke. Danke für die Information.
Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie? Und?
Ja, ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
46 Jahre alt. Wann geboren genau Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1.1.77 geboren.
Ja, erster Tag.
Ja.
Super, ganz gut. Und wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 77,3 Kilo schwer.
77,3 Kilo schwer. Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, mein Gross ist 1,67 Meter.
1,67.
1,67. Groß, alles gut.
Frau Müller, was grüßt Sie uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit heute Morgen wieder Herzrasen.
Das kommt plötzlich und macht mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich Angst.
Es wurde plötzlich schwindelig und ich habe Angst um zu kippen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und es tut mir leid.
Sie haben schon gesagt seit wann Herzrasen?
Seit heute Morgen.
Ich habe das auch zweimal erlebt.
Seit wann zum Beispiel? Vor?
Ja, wie gesagt, das erste Mal war vor zwei Wochen beim Frühstück mit meiner Freundin.
Mir wurde schwindelig und dann bin ich einfach umgekippt.
Ich war ungefähr zwei Minuten weg, Herr Doktor.
Die zweite Attacke war vor zehn Tagen.
Ich verstehe. Okay.
Haben Sie schon gesagt beim Frühstücken mit Ihrem Freund?
Erstmal.
Herr Doktor, wie gesagt habe ich Herzrasen.
Seit etwa zwei Wochen habe ich immer wieder solche Attacke.
Wie gesagt, zweimal.
Und insgesamt viele.
Es fühlt sich sehr schnell an, Herr Doktor.
Ja, okay. Ich verstehe.
Und beim Umkippen, haben Sie Ihre Bewusstsein verloren?
Ja, es sieht so aus, Herr Doktor. Ich habe das erlebt.
Erstmals zwei Minuten.
Herr Herzrasen hat vielleicht 15 Minuten gedauert, aber ungefähr zwei Minuten.
Die Gebiss verloren.
Herr Müller, gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für den Herzrasen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Es kommt einfach so.
Ein Auslöser. Okay, verstehe.
Wie lange dauert eine Attacke besonders in der letzten Mal?
Wenn Sie mit ganzen Attaken meinen, wie gesagt, der Herzrasen hat 15 Minuten gedauert.
Der Schwindel dauert meistens nur 1-2 Minuten.
Schwindel dauert 1-2 Minuten, aber der Herzrasen dauert circa 15 Minuten.
Sie sind gleichzeitig gekommen, Herr Doktor, aber die Dauer ist anders.
Ja, verstehe. Beide sind anders.
Herzrasen und Schwindel kommen miteinander.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Brustschmerzen, Luftnot oder ein enger Gefühl dabei?
Solche Beschwerden habe ich nicht. Aber habe ich noch weitere Beschwerden?
Ich habe auch noch weitere Beschwerden.
Sagen Sie mir einfach, welche Beschwerden haben Sie noch dabei?
Was für eine Beschwerden soll ich Ihnen sagen? Weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor. Bitte lernen Sie.
Ich habe viele Beschwerden, die gesagt, das kommt mir ein bisschen komplizierter.
Ja, Herr Doktor, Sie vereinfachen das.
Haben Sie für diese Beschwerden beim Hausarzt besucht?
Natürlich. Diese Situationen waren für mich sehr ernst. Deswegen war ich im Krankenhaus.
Letzte Woche war ich im Krankenhaus, aber die Ersten haben nichts gefunden und mich wieder nach Hause geschickt.
Warum wurde ich entlassen?
Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, aber wenn es gut geht, sollte man nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Herr Doktor, mir geht es nicht gut. Ich habe zweimal umgekippt und habe Angst davor.
Ich habe wirklich Angst, dass ich wieder umgekippt werde.
Haben Sie dabei auch schon umgekippt oder unwillkürlich Urin verloren?
Ich habe nicht umgekippt, aber leider habe ich eingeschlafen. Das war sehr unangenehm und ein bisschen unangenehm.
War jemand dabei?
Ja, ich war mit meinen Freunden. Wie gesagt, das war sehr peinlich für mich.
Ich verstehe. Es tut mir leid. Haben Sie schon die Zunge gebissen?
Ich habe die Antwort geantwortet.
Entschuldigung, Sie haben gerade Nein gesagt.
Hatten Sie Muskelschwäche?
Was meinen Sie?
Einfach Muskelschwäche.
Nein, das habe ich nicht erlebt.
Haben Sie nur Kribbel oder Tauberheit das Gefühl bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe Kribbel. Manchmal zittern meine Hände und es gibt auch Kribbel.
Manchmal zittern? Nicht immer? Gleichzeitig Hälschen oder Schwinde?
Ja, aber außer der Attacke leide ich darunter, Herr Doktor.
Ich verstehe.
Können Sie mir bitte Ihren Schwindel beschreiben?
Ja, wie ein Boot. Kann ich sagen, wie ein Boot?
Ja, würden Sie bitte noch einmal beschreiben, wie ein Drehschwindel oder ein Schwachschwindel?
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Herr Doktor, ich kann nicht gut beschreiben. Ich bin nicht... Ja.
Aber ich kann sagen nur, wie im Boot.
Ja, okay, okay. Ich verstehe. Alles gut.
Haben Sie Sehstörungen oder Hörstörungen?
Gott sei Dank nicht.
Keine Sehstörungen, keine Hörstörungen.
Sind Sie ein empfindlicher Gegenüberwärmer?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich muss ständig das Fenster ausreißen. Mir ist immer viel zu warm.
Besonders letzte zwei Wochen oder vorher?
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie immer Beschwerden?
Ja, alle Beschwerden verschlimmen sich seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Wochen, ja, ich verstehe. Fühlen Sie sich nervös, Frau Wieland?
Ja, genau, ja. Total. Ich habe auch... Ich kann kaum still sitzen, Herr Doktor.
Ich fühle mich immer nervös und innerlich immer unruhig.
Ja, ich verstehe. Es tut mir leid. Und sind Sie gut konzentriert?
Nein, ich kann auf irgendeine Sache nicht gut konzentrieren, Herr Doktor.
Konzentration, Probleme?
Ja, genau.
Ganz gut. Frau Wieland, in der letzten Zeit, wie ist Ihr Apathie?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen komisch. Mal habe ich seit zwei Tagen richtig heiße Hunger-Attacken, Herr Doktor.
Ich möchte viel essen, ja.
Heiße Hunger-Attacken, ja. Okay.
Ich kann es so beschreiben.
Danach haben Sie einen Gewichtverlänger unbemerkt?
Ja, paradoxischerweise habe ich auch Gewichtsabnahme zunommen.
Trotz Heißhunger?
Ja, ja. Trotzdem habe ich drei bis fünf Kilo in den letzten Wochen ohne Diät zugenommen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Entschuldigung, abgenommen.
Haben Sie Haarausfall gemerkt?
Das habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor. Muss das sein?
Nein. Theoretisch kann es sein, aber es muss nicht sein.
Wie gesagt, bin ich nervös.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Keine Sorge. Machen Sie keine Sorge. Alles wird gut.
Frau Wuler, wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich Durchfall, Herr Doktor.
Durchfall?
Das ist wässrig und interessant. Derweise ist mein Stuhl manchmal auch dünner.
Auch Esseneristen oder Gerple, wie sei es?
Das kann ich nicht gut beschreiben, Herr Doktor.
Ohne Blut?
Ja, es gab kein Blut.
Aber wässrig?
Ja, genau. Und dünner.
Fühlen Sie Schiebrich? Haben Sie Schleiffrost? Nachschweiß?
Ja, wie gesagt, muss ich ständig das Fenster reisen.
Aber wenn ich die Temperatur messe, war es immer normal.
Wie ist es in der Nacht?
Wie bitte?
In der Nacht?
Gehen Sie mit Fieber?
Gibt es einen Nachschweiß auch?
Ich schwitze sehr, Herr Doktor. Aber nicht besonders in der Nacht.
Auch tagsüber leide ich darunter.
Alles gut. Und dann? Haben Sie eine andere Erkrankung? Ist bei Ihnen bekannt?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Bei mir wurde mit 18 Jahren Endosyndrom entdeckt.
Wissen Sie, dass Endometriose eine gebrannte Schleimhautkrankheit ist?
Ja, wir sehen manchmal Endometriose.
Seitdem nehme ich deswegen Minulet, Herr Doktor.
Ja, Minulet.
Mit 25 Jahren hatte ich eine Eileiter Schwangerschaft, die wurde operiert.
Mit 25 Jahren?
Nein, mit 25 Jahren.
Vor ungefähr 20 Jahren?
Ja, vor ungefähr 20 Jahren.
Und dann?
Wie würden Sie behandelt?
Wie gesagt, nehme ich deswegen Medikamente.
Mit Medikamenten.
Minulet, ja.
Was noch?
Mit Vorerkrankung?
Ja, Vorerkrankung. Gott sei Dank habe ich keine andere Erkrankung.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Mit 10 Jahren wurde mir die Mandel entfernt.
Mit 10 Jahren?
Ja, mit 10 Jahren.
Und dann?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Eine Fehldiagnose, Herr Doktor.
Eine Fehldiagnose, ja.
Ehrlich gesagt, seitdem habe ich Schwierigkeiten erstens zu vertrauen, Herr Doktor.
Und dann?
Ja, ich habe es mir vorgegeben.
Ich habe es mir vorgegeben.
Und dann?
Ja, ich habe es mir vorgegeben.
Ehrlich gesagt, seitdem habe ich Schwierigkeiten erstens zu vertrauen, Herr Doktor.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich. Aber, natürlich, nicht so.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, es tut mir sehr leid.
Wegen der Fehldiagnose, aber blinde Erntzündung und Endometriosis kann man echt leicht verwachsen.
Ja, das ist als theoretisch möglich, aber es tut mir leid.
Wegen der vielen Ergebnisse. Alles gut.
Frau Güler, haben Sie Allergie gegen etwas?
Ja, Herr Doktor, gegen Braunhauspflaster bin ich allergisch.
Ich bekomme Schwellung und rote Haut.
Schwellung und rote Haut.
Mitkommand haben Sie schon gesagt, Minulet einmal?
Ja, Herr Doktor, außer Minulet nehme ich bei Bedarf Valdrian.
Valdrian?
Ja, wegen dieser Nervosität und auch, Herr Doktor, ich leide unter Schlafstörungen.
Ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Entschuldigung, leider habe ich diese Frage nach Schlafstörungen vergessen.
Sie haben auch Schlafstörungen.
Ja, deswegen nehme ich Valdrian.
Valdrian. Das hilft Ihnen, oder?
Nein, ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ok, verstanden.
Alles gut. Medikament, Allergen, was noch?
Lebt Ihr Eltern noch?
Nein, Herr Doktor, leider.
Mein Vater ist letztes Jahr an einer Blutverdichtung verstorben.
Er hatte auch Geht- und Alkoholprobleme.
Alkoholprobleme und Geht.
Herr Doktor, wie kann man heutzutage noch an so etwas sterben?
Das klingt mir nicht sinnvoll.
Ja, leider Blutverdichtung, so genannt bei uns selbst,
ist eine schwere Situation.
Eine bedrohliche, lebensbedrohliche Infektion kann sein.
Ja, manchmal. Und sehr gefährlich und sehr schwer.
Ich verstehe.
Entschuldigen Sie, ich bin nicht davon überzeugt.
Und meine Mutter hat Morbus Crohn.
Lebt noch?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Herr Doktor, ich bin offiziell seit fünf Jahren geschieden.
Seitdem habe ich eine Beziehung mit meinen Freunden.
Ja, alles gut. Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Einzelhandel-Kauf-Frau.
Einzelhandel-Kauf-Frau. Alles gut.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Leider nicht.
Wir haben vor, ein adoptives Kind zu bekommen, Herr Doktor.
Sehr gut. Ich gratuliere Sie.
Und letzte Frage. Rauchen Sie, Frau Müller?
Nein, seit 25 Jahren nicht mehr.
Früher so drei, vier Zigaretten.
Super schöne Entscheidung.
Aber früher habe ich geraucht. Aber nicht so viel.
Drei, vier Zigaretten am Tag.
Acht Jahre lang habe ich geraucht.
Ja. Aber letzte 25 Jahre.
Brauche ich nicht.
Gut zu hören.
Tanken Sie Alkohol? Wie oft?
Ja, zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche ungefähr.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Fragen nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie mal Drogen ausprobiert?
An der Universität habe ich zweimal probiert.
Aber außer das habe ich nie probiert.
Beim Studium.
Alles gut, Frau Müller.
Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich bedanke mich für Ihre Offenheit.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Herr Doktor, was habe ich?
Was würden Sie sagen?
Frau Müller, Sie haben eine Erdacht auf Schilddrüse.
Schilddrüse, Oberfunktion.
Aber ich habe viele Schilddrüse.
Interessant.
Ich habe viele verschiedene Probleme.
Sie haben ganz recht. Schilddrüse ist ein sehr wichtiges hormongebendes Organ.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Aufgaben.
Schilddrüse, Wärmeteigungen, Temperatur, Schleifstoffe.
Schilddrüse, Wärmeteigungen, Temperatur, Schleifstoffwechsel.
Energieverbrauch, Laune, Nervosität.
Und Kalkulanz, Regulation.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Aufgaben.
Von der Schilddrüse könnte es sein, aber das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Erstmal körperliche Untersuchungen.
Dann würde ich Blut für die Labor abnehmen.
Dann zum Beispiel ein EKG.
Und noch weitere Prozedure.
Und bitte warten Sie auf mich hier.
Und ich werde dann zurücksehen.
Danke Herr Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Herr Doktor, wir haben 28 Minuten lang zu Ende.
Danke.
Ich habe ein bisschen Zeit verhäutigt, die Laboraroma und die Formatik zu machen.
So dass es ein Wochenende dauert.
So, dann beginnen wir.
Ekrem, wann beginnen wir?
Du hast deinen Mund kaputt.
Du hast deinen Mund kaputt, deswegen habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich habe auch nicht in meinem Mund gesungen.
Ich habe mich falsch beigetragen.
Herr Doktor, wir beginnen morgen.
Wir können heute beginnen, aber ich habe meine ersten Worte vergessen.
Dann beginnen wir morgen.
Kling, kling.
Morgen ist der Herr Ibrahim.
Nein, wir beginnen.
Wir beginnen?
Wir beginnen.
Kling, kling.
Herr Müller am Apparat.
Ich habe eine wichtige Laborwerte von Frau Müller.
Es geht um 2 Kalium Spiegel.
Das ist 2,53 Millimol pro Liter.
Bitte diese Formatformen teilen mit Ihrem Oberarzt.
Kaliumwerte?
Kaliumwerte 2,53 Millimol pro Liter.
3 Millimol pro Liter. Danke für die Information.
Tschüss.
Alles gut. Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herzlich willkommen. Woher kommen Sie, Herr Özdemaz?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Ok. Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Ca. 3 Jahre bin ich in Deutschland.
Ca. 3 Jahre? Das ist nicht so kurz. Was haben Sie gemacht?
In diesen 3 Jahren habe ich 3-mal Deutschkurs besucht.
Als B1, dann Integration, dann B2 und noch eine kleine kurze Zeit für den Spiegel-Kurs.
Und dann ca. 7 Monate Hospitalisierung gemacht.
7 Monate? Wow, super.
Welche Fachrichtung haben Sie eine Hospitalisierung gemacht?
Erstmals 3 Monate Gastroenterologie-Hospitation, dann 3 Monate Urologie und dann 1 Monat Allgemeinschülung.
Viele Ärzte oder Ärzte sagten, dass eine Hospitalisierung sehr schwer ist.
Wie konnten Sie diese Hospitalisierung finden? Ich bin sehr erfreut darauf.
Ich empfehle meinen Kollegen und Kolleginnen, am Anfang habe ich viele E-Mails geschrieben.
Ich habe viele Ärzte und Krankenhäuser, viele Ärzte und Abteilungen, jeden Tag 5-4 E-Mails geschrieben.
Aber leider habe ich keine Antwort bekommen.
Ich versuche es direkt zu besuchen, zum Klinik.
Ich habe direkt mit dem Chefsekretär besucht.
Dann habe ich 3 Mal Hospitalisierung gemacht.
Ok. Hauptsache, Sie sind direkt mit Chefärzt oder Klinikabteilung?
Ja, ich empfehle meinen Kollegen direkt Kontakt.
Man sollte direkt mit der Klinik in Verbindung setzen, nicht nur E-Mails.
Aber ich habe einen Fehler gemacht.
Vielleicht ist eine Chirurgische Station für uns nicht so gut.
Denn im Operraum täglich, tagsüber in einem Operraum zu bleiben, ist nicht so gut für unsere Deutsch-Erfahrung.
Deutsch zu verbessern?
Ja, Deutsch zu verbessern ist nicht so gut.
Während der OP sprechen die Leute nicht so viel?
Ja, natürlich. Eine Schwester, ein Oberarzt, das gibt es sehr kleine.
Aber trotzdem könnten Sie während der OP etwas lernen.
Vielleicht können die Leute sehr kurze in einer Chirurgischen Station eine Hospitalisierung machen.
3 Monate lang ist vielleicht ein bisschen lang für eine Chirurgische Station.
Aber für uns ist es besser, bei der Aufklärung zu bleiben oder zu führen.
Oder beim Anamnesgespräch zu teilen oder mitmachen.
Ich empfehle nicht eine Chirurgische Station.
Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen. Ich möchte ihn vorstellen.
Es geht um Frau Maja Wüller, 46 Jahre alt.
Wollen Sie mir Ihren Patienten vorstellen?
Haben Sie noch andere wichtige Informationen?
Ja, ich habe gerade eine wichtige Information aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich möchte erst einmal mit Ihnen teilen.
Herr Müller, Kaliumwerte 2,3 mmol pro Liter.
2,53 mmol pro Liter.
2,3, ich verstehe.
Nach dem Komma sagen wir nun Nummer.
Was bedeutet das?
Das bedeutet Hypokaliemi.
Was ist normaler Bereich?
Normaler Bereich ist 3,5 und 5,5.
Normaler Bereich ist 2,53.
Hypokaliemi spricht.
Ich weiß, dass die normale Bereich von Hypokaliemi aus der Klinik ist.
Ich weiß, dass die normale Bereich von Kaliumwerte 3,6 bis 5,2 mmol pro Liter sind.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Verständnisse im Laufe der Laboren.
Jeder Krankenhaus und jeder Labor hat eine andere Standardwerte.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Aber unsere Laboreferenzwerte, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, was haben Sie noch?
Ich habe alle neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Es geht um Frau Müller, Meier Müller, geborener, 1.1.1977.
Sie ist 1,87 m groß und 7,3 kg.
Frau Müller stellt sich heute bei uns wegen der plötzlich aufgetretenen Attacken vor.
Jede Episode dauert etwa 15 Minuten.
Frau Müller beschreibt seit zwei Wochen vier Attacken von Schwindel.
Jede Attacke dauert ca. ein oder zwei Minuten.
Laut Angaben der Patienten ist sie heute Morgen umgekriebt.
Außerdem hatte sie letzte zwei Wochen zwei Episode von Schwindel mit unwillkürlicher und gewaltiger Mischung.
Entschuldigung, ist sie heute Morgen umgekriebt oder sie hat Angst vor umkriegen?
Ich gucke meine Note. Heute Morgen umgekriegt.
Ich habe gehört, sie hat Angst vor umkriegen. Sie hat heute Morgen Angst vor umkriegen.
Früher ist sie zweimal umgekriegt.
Erste war vor zwei Wochen, zweite war vor zehn Tagen.
Heute Morgen ist sie nicht umgekriegt.
Oda, Çetin Hoca?
Sie ist zweimal umgekriegt.
Entschuldigung, sie ist heute Morgen Angst vor umkriegen.
Vorher hat sie zweimal vor zehn Tagen und drei Tagen umgekriegt.
Vor zehn Tagen und zwei Wochen?
Vor zehn Tagen und zwei Wochen umgekriegt.
Außerdem hatte sie letzte zwei Wochen zwei Episode mit unwillkürlicher Mischung, aber ohne gewissenes Zunge.
Wann hatte sie unwillkürliche Erkörungen?
Beide umgekriegt vor zehn Tagen.
Während des Umkriegen hatte sie?
Während des Umkriegen.
Krämpfe wurden verneint.
Begleitend waren Wärmeintoleranz, Nervosität, Konzentrationsstörung und die Hände.
Eine Gewichtabnahme von fünf Kilo in vier Wochen.
Trotz Heißhunger, Hyperhydrose, Durchfall, Hyperhydrose und Durchfall.
Ein-, zweimal täglich seit zwei Wochen.
Die Bekämpfung ist unaufhörbar auf Insomnias.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Bei der Vorerkrankung erwähnte sie Endometriose.
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung.
Hat sie Vergrößerung im Hals?
Der Patient habe ich nicht gefragt.
Okay.
Diese Frage habe ich leider vergessen.
Bei der Vorerkrankung erwähnte sie Endometriose.
Als Operation wurde sie konservativ behandelt.
Als Operation gab es eine Tontolektomie mit sechster Lebensjahr.
Und eine Appendektomie mit achter Lebensjahr.
Und mit 25. Lebensjahr eine extrauterin Gravitat.
Eine Medikamentnimmung.
Einmal täglich und bazig bei Bedarf.
Bei der Allergienanamnese erwähnte sie eine Allergie gegen Pflaster.
Sie reagierte auf Juckreis, Erdhemm und Pyrrhythus.
Bei der Noxenanamnese gab es seit 25 Jahren Mitrauch.
Im Akkoholkonsum wurden zwei Gläser am Wochenende bejaht.
Und familiell an der Nase ergab sich der Vater wegen einer Blutvergiftung, Sepsis, verstorben.
Der Vater hatte eine Akkoholsucht und gicht.
Die Mutter war morgens pro.
Sozialanwässlich ist sie Verkäuferin.
Ich erinnere mich nicht an Einzelhandel, Kaufraue.
Sie war nur mit ihren Freunden. Sie hatte keine Kinder.
Aufgrund der Allergienanamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf Hyperhydrosis.
Hyperhydrosis?
Hyperthyrosis. Entschuldigung.
Hab ich Hyperhydrosis gesagt.
Hyperthyrosis.
Die Phalanse Diagnostik kommen.
Herzlose Störungen und Trans ischämische Attack in Betracht.
Wofür spricht Hyperthyrosis?
Hyperthyrosis spricht Tachycardi, Nervosität, Konzentrationsstörung, Wärmeintoleranz, Gewichtverlust, Gärö.
Ich bin dafür.
Und?
Warum haben Sie an Trans ischämische Attack gedacht?
Welche Symptome sprechen für Trans ischämische Attack?
Die Patientin sagte, sie hat vor zwei Wochen umgekippt und bis zu einem Verlust beschrieben.
Sie war total eingenehm.
Und sie leidet unter Kribbelgefühl?
Ja, Kribbelgefühl.
Hab ich gehört? Sie leidet unter Kribbelgefühl.
Vorübergehende Kribbelgefühl.
Und Kribbelgefühl.
Was noch?
Kribbelgefühl.
Hat sie nicht Palästhesien oder Tremor gesagt.
Nur Kribbelgefühl und bis zu einem Verlust.
Okay.
Um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich gerne als Erster seine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Eine Schildkursum untersuchen.
Durchführen.
Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Blutbild, Leber und Nierenwerte und Träuchthormone.
TSH, T3, T4.
Träuchthormone.
Neuroxidation.
Antikörperlabor.
Vitalparameter.
Überwachen.
Einen EKG schreiben.
Und eine endoknologische Konzilanfordung.
Welche operative Methode benutzen Sie?
Was ist das für eine Diagnose?
Eine operative Methode.
Eine operative Methode für die Diagnose.
Um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Eine operative Methode, die ich auch mitbekommen habe.
Etwa ein Ultraschall.
Danke für die Information.
Ich schreibe als erstes eine Hassultraschall.
Und vielleicht eine Synthographie.
Troidsynthographie.
Machen Sie sofort eine Troidsynthographie?
Nein. Am Anfang nur Hassultraschall.
Gibt es eine Vergrößerung oder Asymmetrie?
Oder heterogen Gewebe?
Gibt es eine Lymphknoten- oder Nodulinformation?
Ich achte darauf, diese Befunde bei der Ultraschall.
Und dann möchte ich weitere Verfahren.
Zum Beispiel eine Troidsynthographie.
Und als nächstes möchte ich eine endoknologische Konzilanfordung.
Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Ich werde die Patienten auf die Station aufnehmen.
Und dann eine Flüssigkeit und elektrische Subvention geben.
Und können Sie mir bitte helfen meine Empfehlung?
Ich möchte Sie auf die Droide ein Betablocker verreiben.
Warum verreiben Sie einen Betablocker?
Wegen Herzrhythmus.
Wegen Herzrhythmus. Okay.
Was verschreiben Sie noch?
Vielleicht haben Sie gesagt, aber leider muss ich mein Verbindungsgerät wechseln.
Deswegen habe ich nicht gehört.
Aus Betablocker Antitroid Medikament.
Was bedeutet Antitroid Medikament?
Mit Muscle.
Trostatika.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Danke für die Information.
Trostatika.
Leider nicht.
Meine Empfehlung.
Das war es.
Können Sie mir bitte helfen?
Ja natürlich.
Ich möchte diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Wegen zweimaliger Senkopen.
Danach sollte die Patientin eine symptomatische Behandlung wie Betablocker
und auch nach den Ergebnissen der Labowerte
eine Trostatika verschrieben werden.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Präsentation.
Okay.
Ibrahim Hocam?
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Frau Oberastlin.
Haben Sie eine kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja natürlich.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten gesehen.
Ich möchte Ihnen etwas wichtiges mit teilen.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Es geht um Frau Müller.
Sie hat einen Kaliumspiegel von 2,3 Millimitern pro Liter.
Das heißt Hypokalämie.
Nun möchte ich Ihnen gerne neue Patienten vorstellen.
Ja bitte schön.
Frau Mayer-Wüller ist ein 46-jähriger Patient.
Sie ist am 01.01.1977 geboren.
Sie wiegt ungefähr 77,3 Kilo.
Ihr großer ist 1,67 Meter.
Frau Müller kam heute zu uns wegen Tachikade und Angst von Kippen.
Sie hatte zweimal ähnliche Attacken.
Das erste Mal war vor zwei Wochen.
Das zweite Mal war vor zehn Tagen.
Frau Müller erklärt, dass sie zweimal den Kopf abhattet.
Sie hat gleichzeitig Herzrasen.
Sie erwähnte die Unwillkürlichmischung vor zehn Tagen.
Sie begleitet sich mit einer Nervosität, einem warmen Gefühl, einem Tremor, einer Parasthesie, einem vermissten Appetit.
Die Vegetative-Anamnese ist unaufwendig.
Sie hat Schlafstörungen.
Sie erwähnte, dass sie gegen Baldrian-Drehen bei Bedarf eingenommen haben.
Sie hat eine Operation.
Wir können Sie ganz genau verstehen. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wir warten auf Sie.
Sie ist unaufwendig.
Sie leidet an Endometriasis.
Sie erwähnte, dass sie eine Operation hatten.
und im selben Jahr sind Appendektome vorhanden.
Frau Wuler erwähnt, dass die Allergie gegen Braunblaster
aus der Sicht der Ödämmer und der Eritern.
Frau Wuler ist nur nicht Raucherin seit 25 Jahren,
aber früher seit 18 Jahren lang ungefähr 1 Ackertigereit geraucht.
Sind Sie sicher?
Ich muss kontrollieren.
Sie ist momentan nicht Raucherin, aber früher hat sie nur 3 bis 4 Zigaretten täglich ungefähr 8 Jahre lang geraucht.
Ich habe eine Notizen gemacht, seit 25 Jahren sind sie nicht Raucherin,
aber früher 8 Jahre lang 1 Ackertigereit geraucht.
8 Jahre lang 3 oder 3 bis 4 Zigaretten täglich?
3 bis 4, Entschuldigung.
Die Frau Wuler trinkt am Wochenende 1 bis 2 Gleise Wein.
Die Familie Anamnese hat ihren Vater an einem Stepsis verstorben.
Ihr Mutter lebt noch.
Ihr Mutter hat Modus Crohn.
Unser Patient ist Einzelhandelkäufer, Koff-Frau.
Sie ist erschienen und hat keine Kinder.
Ist sie erschienen?
Ja, aber sie hat eine feste Beziehung.
Ich habe nicht gehört, ob sie erschienen ist.
Nach der Anamnestige Angebe habe ich einen Verdacht auf die Schieferperiode.
Zuerst werden noch nicht die Pferde verwendet.
Herzrhythmusstörungen und transische ischämische Atak in Betracht.
Um die Verdachtstheoretik zu verhindern, würde ich gerne eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Danach werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Anschließend werde ich die Droiduklage veranlassen.
Ich werde die Diagnostik von Blutbildern, Droidhormonen, Leberwärtser, Herzmuskelenzymen,
und Cholesterinspiegel kontrollieren.
Als Therapie werde ich eine Ambulanz behandeln.
Für die Tachikardie empfehle ich Beta-Blocker.
Für die Hyperthyroase würde ich eine Therapie verabreichen.
Danach werde ich ein Doktornisches Konzil anfolgen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich werde jetzt die Tachikardie veranlassen.
Ich werde die Diagnostik von Blutbildern veranlassen.
Ich habe die Tachikardie veranlagt.
Die Tachikardie hat eine Tachikardie.
vor 10 Tagen und während des Senkopes z.B. hier angenasst, aber ich denke, es ist sehr
schrecklich, dass es angenasst ist.
Dann müssen wir die Epileptische Anfalle denken.
Deswegen denke ich, dass dies ein späteres verwendetes, falsches Wissen ist.
Aber hier z.B. gesagt, während des Senkopes hat sie angenasst, aber die zungegebissenen
Muskelkrampfe, Muskelzuckungen wurden verneint.
Sie erwähnt, dass sie gleichzeitig Schwindelattacke hat.
Und die Schwindel ist schwanker oder direkt Schwankerschwindelattacke hat.
Und jede Attacke dauert 1 oder 2 Minuten.
Und danach begleitet, begleitend klagt sie über andere alle.
Warme Intoleranz, Hyperhydrose, Nervosität, Konzentrationsstörungen und Diorä, Gewichtsabnahme
und die Schwindelattacke.
Und wenn sie in der Schwindelattacke aufgehoben ist, dann ist sie in der Schwindelattacke.
So wie ich es bisher gemacht habe, so lange es in der Schwindelattacke war.
Ich habe alles in meinem Kopf, aber es ist etwas schwer, diese Formalität zu formulieren.
Definitiv.
Es ist sehr schwierig, diese Formalität zu formulieren.
Es ist sehr schwierig, die Fragen zu fragen.
Jetzt versuche ich euch, wie ich die Fragen formuliere.
Es ist wirklich ein schwieriger Fall.
Ich habe hier die Frage gestellt, dass der Patient mit Herzrasen und Umkippen-Korpsen kommt.
Ich habe die Anzeige immer, was ich jetzt alles machen soll, gesucht.
Das tut mir leid, dass ich das nicht verstanden habe.
Sie hatten Herzrasen und Angst vor Umkippen.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt, was ich von ihm gehört habe.
Ich werde die Frage zurückgeben, damit sie das richtig versteht.
Ich habe alles gehört, was ich gesagt habe.
Aber ich werde die Frage jetzt nicht alles lernen.
Ich werde es immer wieder in der Hand machen.
Ich sage, dass ich das gehört habe.
Sie hatten Herzrasen und Angst vor Umkippen.
Sie hatten Angst vor Umkippen.
Was habe ich gemacht?
Ich bin jetzt mit dem Symptom beschäftigt.
Sie hatten Herzrasen und Angst vor Umkippen.
Ich habe mit dem Symptom beschäftigt.
Das ist kein Problem.
Aber ich habe die zwei Fragen beantworten.
Zuerst werde ich umkippen.
Dann wird er sagen, dass ich umkippen habe.
Nach dem Zwischenbewerb, der ich jetzt gut verstanden habe,
werde ich überprüfen.
Ich frage mich, ob ich das richtig bin.
Während des Umkippens haben Sie einen Genas oder die Zunge gebissen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Muskelkrampfe, Muskelzucken haben?
Schauen Sie, was ich mache.
Hier ist Zenkop.
Ich frage Sie, ob Sie ein Umgekipp sind.
Ich frage Sie, ob Sie ein Zenkop sind.
Während des Umkippens haben Sie einen Genas oder die Zunge gebissen.
Ist das ein Genas oder eine Zunge gebissen?
Und dann haben Sie eine Zunge gebissen.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu dem Genas.
Was ist wichtig?
Wann ist es wichtig?
Ist es immer so?
Oder kommt es in die Form von Zungen?
Wie lange sind die Zunge gebissen?
Ich habe die ganze Zeit gelernt.
Wenn Sie das fragen, haben Sie eine Zunge gebissen.
Sie haben eine Zunge gebissen.
Wie ist die Zunge gebissen?
Wenn Sie nicht die Zunge gebissen haben,
können Sie die Zunge nicht gebissen haben.
Sie haben eine Zunge gebissen.
Sie haben die Zunge gebissen.
Was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu der Zunge gebissen.
Wie ist die Zunge gebissen?
Ich frage die neurologischen Fragen.
Sie können sich noch andere Bechwerden bewegen, die gleichzeitig auftreten.
Zum Beispiel vielleicht...
...die anderen Bechwerden.
Um von ihnen zu lernen, kann man so einen Geflüchteten machen.
Vielleicht haben sie eine Intoleranz oder sie sind nervös.
Man kann die anderen Bechwerden von dort erwarten.
Ihr müsst nicht alle fragen.
Oder ich habe es so gemacht, was ich von ihnen beantwortet habe.
Haben sie eine Fertigungsstelle, die sie nicht verbreitet hat?
Ob sie das hat oder nicht?
Ich habe sie so gefragt, um zu fragen.
Und dann habe ich sie immer wieder gefragt.
Gibt es andere Bechwerden, die Gleisheite auftreten, die Hyperturose beitragen?
Ich habe sie ein paar Symptome gesagt.
Wenn man den Patienten zu Beginn schon entspannt hat,
dann sagt man, dass die ganzen Symptome zusammengesungen werden.
So ist es.
Das war das.
Dann geht man zu Vegetative Anamnesia.
Du hast einige Beispiele vorgelegt.
Sie haben einige davon gesagt.
Obwohl sie nicht alle gesagt haben, geht man zu Vegetative Anamnesia.
Dort fragt man sich, ob sie Fibat, Tülfros, nach Schweiß, Kaiswaz oder Schweißausbruch haben.
Dort sagt man etwa Schweiß.
Wenn man es nicht sagt, ist es ein Problem.
Das ist die Diöres.
Weil sie eine Frau ist und nicht sehr alt ist,
ist Ginecologie Anamnesia wichtig.
Es gibt keine Probleme.
Aber Hyperturose kann ein erhöhtes Menarche sein.
Es kann ein Unregelmäßiges oder ein Regelblutung sein.
Deswegen ist Ginecologie Anamnesia hier gut zu fragen.
Es ist kein großer Fehler, das Anwesen zu vergessen.
Aber es kann gut sein, dass es weiter geht.
Das war mein Formalisierungsformat.
Ich hoffe, ich habe es nicht zu viel gesagt.
Danke, Herr Hübner.
Ich nehme alles, was der Patient sagt.
Ich untersuche die Anastomaten, die er sagt.
Ich stelle die restlichen.
Ich stelle ein, zwei Beispiele.
Wenn er sagt, sagt er, wenn er nicht sagt.
Ich werde die meisten von Vegetative Anamnesia schon lernen.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Hübner, ich habe eine kleine Frage.
In diesen Protokollen oder Anamnesia-Sprichs
gibt es auch Dinge.
Der Patient hat sich oder seine Kliniker
mit Alkohol beschäftigt.
Alkohol hat Probleme.
Ist es richtig, hier Alkohol zu beherbergen?
Oder gibt es solche Dinge in Erfarungen?
Was denkst du psychisch?
Ich habe Karten mit Alkohol.
Oder Missbrauch.
Manche kümmern sich um Zucht.
Ist es richtig, wenn der Patient mit einer
Aussage von Alkoholprobleme
zu beherbergen,
oder ist es nicht ein Problem?
Es ist kein Problem.
Ihr müsst nicht sich beherbergen.
Ich beherberge, ob ich schlecht bin.
Es ist nicht wichtig.
Der einzige, der auf Alkoholprobleme
betrachtet wird, ist der Vakant von Pankratitis.
Ansonsten gibt es keine anderen Dinge.
Die Mutter und der Vater haben auch Alkoholprobleme.
Die Doktorin schaut nicht, wie sie das geschrieben hat.
Aber es ist wichtig, wie der Patient es erzählt.
Wenn der Patient es so ausdrückt,
aber ich habe so etwas nie gehört,
dann kann man das als Zuchtig oder Abüß sagen.
Aber wenn er es so nicht sagt,
dann kann man auch auf Alkoholkonsum schreiben.
Das ist sicherer.
Man weiß nicht, wie viel man von der Mutter und der Vater
getrunken hat.
Der Patient sagt, dass er viel getrunken hat.
Aber man kann es als Verdacht aufschreiben.
Aber Alkoholkonsum ist sicherer.
Ja, das ist sicherer.
Es ist kein Problem.
Die Reaktionen.
Das wichtigste an den Reaktionen ist,
was wir zu Beginn gemacht haben.
Das tut mir leid, dass ich das nicht getrunken habe.
Das ist sehr ansietlich.
Deswegen ist man sehr bescheid.
Aber wir sind jetzt in guten Händen.
Wir werden unser bestes Physik.
Wir werden heute die Urzae wieder verdienen.
Ich habe die Entlassungbrüfte bei mir.
Ich habe die Anzeige, ob ihr die Brüfte bei mir habt.
Die Brüfte ist nicht bei mir.
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, warum sie entlassen werden.
Aber ich kann sie nicht sagen.
Wir werden die notwendigen Untersuchungen
durchführen, um die genaue Urzae zu finden.
Das war es.
Aber ich habe die Entlassungbrüfte nicht gesehen.
Ich habe mir gesagt, dass ich sie nicht beantworten kann.
Aber es ist nicht nötig,
und wir werden alles, was wir brauchen, hier machen.
Das war es.
Dann kam eine Reaktion.
Die Beziehung mit Tommy und Andomitriöse.
Das tut mir leid, dass Sie so sehr verhaut sind.
Ich bin wirklich sehr verhaut,
und ich bin wirklich sehr verhaut.
Aber Andomitriöse kann ein Bild der Bildarmentzündung
von Tauschen vertauschen.
Andomitriöse kann mit einem Appendicit-Tablos
verhaut werden.
Deswegen war die Operation mantiklich.
Dann kann ich mir vertrauen,
dass ich meine besten Gewissen und Wissen
an sie behalten kann.
Ich kann mir das bestätigen.
Ich habe mit meinem besten Wissen und Wissen
etwas gesagt, das ich Ihnen mit meinem Wissen
und Wissen umsetzen kann.
Dann kann ich Ihnen das Wissen und Wissen
umsetzen.
Natürlich, das kannst du auch so sagen.
Wenn wir nicht in Technik gehen...
Das kannst du auch so sagen.
Das kannst du noch kurz sagen.
Du kannst direkt nur das sagen.
Ich bin total frustriert.
Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen.
Das ist alles.
Ich muss mir nicht sagen, dass ich mir aufregen muss.
Es gibt auch eine Reaktion von Sepsis,
die Vater der Kinder verletzt.
Ja, das habe ich auch.
Ich wollte es so sagen.
Es ist leider oft möglich,
dass die Menschen wegen der Blutvergiftung
sterben.
Besonders, wenn sie das sehr spät erkennen
und sehr spät behandelt werden.
Aber natürlich hat die Medizin viele
Fortschritte.
So würde ich es sagen.
Heute ist es möglich, dass die Menschen
aus allen anderen Orten sterben.
Besonders, wenn sie zu spät kennen
und zu spät behandelt werden.
Aber natürlich hat die Medizin auch
viele Fortschritte.
Ich habe immer nur die Normen.
Ich sage immer etwas,
was mir die Menschen weiter erlauben.
So habe ich es so gemacht.
Was ist das?
Ist es etwas, was du sagen willst?
Du machst die Prozesse in der Woche?
Wir verhören die Prozesse.
Die Prozesse werden von uns aus
von den Medizinern ausgesprochen.
Ja, jetzt, ab dem nächsten Tag,
wie meine Freunde ihre Prozesse
in der Arbeit machen,
das erzähle ich dir.
Danke.
Ich habe noch eine kleine Frage.
Ich habe es vor der Vorbereitung gemacht.
Ich habe es in den Erfarungen nicht gelesen,
aber ich habe es nicht in den Erfarungen gelesen.
Hat der Patient eine Reaktion oder
eine gewünschte Reaktion
oder eine gewünschte Reaktion
in den Erfarungen?
Oder wie soll man das beantworten?
Das erinnere ich mich nicht.
Aber es ist mir sehr schade,
etwas Besonderes zu sagen.
Denn was braucht es in dieser Gesellschaft?
Eine Reaktion zu geben,
das ist ein Problem.
Deswegen ist es etwas,
das ich verständlich bin.
Das ist etwas ganz normales.
Wenn ich marriede bin,
wenn ich sagen würde,
dass ich noch marriede bin,
dann würde ich keine Reaktion geben.
Aber es gibt einen Patienten,
den ich nicht erinnern kann.
Ist das sein Sohn?
Er war gestern im Kuhl.
Er steht auf ihm und
in Erfarungen,
ich glaube, er ist ein bisschen
verletzt.
Ich weiß nicht genau,
was er tun soll.
Aber es ist etwas,
was man da machen kann.
Eine Reaktion
kann da werden.
Wenn man sich
für einen Patienten
verletzt,
kann man das so sagen.
Man kann das so sagen.
Ich verstehe,
dass man sich für einen Patienten
verletzt.
Vielleicht ist es so,
dass man für einen Patienten
eine Reaktion verletzt.
Vielleicht ist mein Reddit
nicht richtig,
aber man kann das so sagen.
Man kann das so sagen.
Mein моter hat zwei Kinder,
das ist schon so.
Man kann das so sagen,
wenn man im Moment einfach ist.
Das ist schon, das ist mein Sohn.
Das ist mein Sohn.
Das ist meine Sohn.
Das ist meine Sohn,
Jeder entscheidet seine eigene Meinung.
Oder wenn man sich die Düsseldorf-Pirate aus dem Grundein und der Religion ausprobiert.
Nein, ich trinke keinen Alkohol. Ich habe nicht probiert.
Wenn man sich die Religion ausprobiert, kann man mir das beantworten. Ich habe nicht probiert.
Es ist kein Grund, Religion in die Religion zu verbreiten.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so.
Du bist richtig.
Herr Sümeyra, wir hatten einen Patient.
Sein Sohn hat eine andere Geschlechtsmöglichkeit.
Er war in Stress. Er war in Stress.
Ja, das haben wir gerade gesprochen.
Das ist seine Wahl, oder?
Ja, das ist seine Wahl.
Ich verstehe nicht, was Sie sagen, aber...
Man hat seine eigene Meinung.
Kann man eine Forderung der Stimme schreiben?
Ich habe sie als Enttäuschung gefunden, aber...
Ich kann dir etwas sagen. Das kann in Englisch sein.
Ich habe es in Englisch gesagt.
Ja, ich habe es in Englisch gesagt.
Enttäuschung.
Okay, das war eine große Enttäuschung für Sie.
Okay, okay.
Entschuldigung.
Okay, dann sind wir heute fertig.
Für heute fertig.
Wir werden morgen weiter mit der Forderung.
Ich möchte nur, dass wir den Sitz aufhalten können.
Können wir morgen eine Veränderung machen?
Nein, das ist kein Thema.